to cut a long story short a blockchain
is a digital database
bitcoin uses its blockchain to keep a
record of every transaction that's ever
been made dating all the way back to
when the cryptocurrency first launched
on january the 3rd 2009
but there are a few things that make
blockchain special
traditional databases can often be
edited because they are typically
maintained by centralized authorities
such as governments or corporations
this can lead to manipulation and means
that trust in the database is completely
reliant on the trustworthiness of the
governing authority
but blockchains are different
they are immutable and that means the
information they store cannot be changed
traditional databases can also be
private meaning they can only be viewed
by a small number of people by
comparison the bitcoin and ethereum
blockchains are completely decentralized
allowing anyone to download a copy of
the database for themselves
because these blockchains are
distributed across thousands of
computers around the world the networks
are much more difficult to take down
blockchains also deliver transparency
online explorers allow you to track
where bitcoin and ether is sent and how
much is stored in individual crypto
wallets
this can be especially valuable after a
hack because the world can see where
stolen funds end up
so
how does a blockchain work
whenever bitcoin is sent from one person
to another details about the transaction
are sent to the blockchain to be
confirmed
these transactions are bundled together
into a block covering all of the
payments that happened in a specific
period
this block is then attached to the
blocks that came before it creating a
chain of blocks
now you can see why this is called the
blockchain
a new block is created every 10 minutes
and once it's been added to the network
all previous blocks are practically
impossible to edit
this helps keep the blockchain secure
there are several types of blockchain
out there
the most common is proof of work and
this is the one that's used by bitcoins
network
proof of work helps to eliminate the
risk that the same cryptocurrency can
end up being spent twice
something that would inflate supply and
cause prices to fall
miners are responsible for ensuring that
the bitcoin blockchain runs smoothly
in order to be chosen to add the next
block to the blockchain miners need to
complete a complex mathematical puzzle
one that takes a lot of computing power
to solve
this computing power proves some work
was done
there are downsides to this approach
especially because the bitcoin network
ends up using a lot of energy and it
can't complete transactions quickly
another alternative is proof of stake
this type of blockchain eliminates the
need for miners altogether
that's because they are replaced by
validators people who lock up their
coins in order to play a role in keeping
the network secure
those who stake the most coins have a
greater chance of being selected to add
a new block to the blockchain
although this uses a lot less energy
than proof of work there are downsides
one of them is that validators can end
up being penalized if they act against
the network's best interests meaning
their stake is slashed and they lose
crypto
over the past 13 years trilemma of
blockchain characteristics has formed
an ideal blockchain network should be
widely decentralized infinitely scalable
and impenetrably secure but achieving
all three at once is difficult
scalability in particular is a big
challenge
right now the main bitcoin blockchain
can only handle seven transactions per
second while ethereum can handle 13.
by comparison the likes of visa can
handle thousands per second
this means that blockchains can suffer
from congestion
it can take a long time for transactions
to be finalized and this causes fees to
go through the roof
thankfully solutions are beginning to
emerge
layer 2 blockchains can allow
transactions to be confirmed faster
as their name suggests they sit on top
of a network an extra layer to ensure
things run smoothly
one of the most popular layer 2
solutions for bitcoin is the lightning
network
this reduces congestion by allowing
payments to take place instantly and off
the blockchain
details about transactions are then
simplified and added to the main network
later
blockchains have countless other uses
aside from cryptocurrencies
for example they can help ensure that
sensitive data such as medical records
can be shared securely
these tamper-proof databases are also
useful for recording other forms of
information such as who owns a
non-fungible token
blockchains can also shake up supply
chains keeping track of how items are
produced every step of the way
this can be vastly more efficient and
safer than old-fashioned methods
food safety is a good example
there have been incidents where
vegetables have been contaminated
meaning they need to be recalled as fast
as possible
before blockchain existed this process
could take up to seven days but now it's
been slashed to just two seconds
luxury brands have also started to
embrace blockchain in the world of
designer goods counterfeiting can be a
real problem meaning fake handbags can
be sold to unsuspecting consumers
the blockchain can provide proof that a
product is real this technology is still
very young and very new
potential use cases for blockchain are
emerging all of the time and who knows
the biggest and best idea may still be
undiscovered
if you enjoyed the video be sure to
leave a like and a comment